en vente demain matin le nouveau disque
des Rolling Stones Harlem shaffle Mike
Jager avait fait savoir aux enfants du
rock qu'il ne voulait en parler qu'à
Antenne 2 Dionet et manœuvre se sont
exécutés bien volontiers et sont allés
retrouver les Rolling Stones version 86
dans le confort d'un hôtel
londonien regardez bien ces hommes sont
des légendes vivant ils ont survécu à 26
ans de rock and roll et mardi dernier à
Londres il recevait satell un GR Award
la plus haute distinction offerte par le
show business à ses
P vous êtes toujours un groupe l'album
solo c'était juste un épisode non jeis
peut-être un
autre c'est pas exactement quand est-ce
qu'il va y avoir une tournée des Rolling
Stones bientôt pas bientôt peut-être
dans le futur mais pas à
CST les Rolling Stones sont enregistrés
plus de 5 albums en France près des 5
derniers ont été enregistré en France
est-ce que vous vous sentez comme le
premier groupe
français CIT c'est moche ça euh oui je
sa c'est le 5e c'est 5e h oui mais ouis
que ça fin
séri un nveauone aujourd'hui pour la
première fois depuis très longtemps
c'est un disque exceptionnel
[Musique]
pouroies
dis
beaucoup
you used to be the out of rock and roll
bad drugdict and now you seem to be ch
man Family Man is it true it's called
age whether it's true or not I don't
know I live my life pretty much the same
i I gave up I couldn't do it
anymore for obvious reasons many reasons
you know and I guess to a certain extent
m you don't you nobody stays the same
you
know
[Musique]
que pense M Jager de la politique
intérieure française les politique de la
France c'est peu compliqué pour un
étranger de comprendre hein est-ce que
tu sais qui est le président en ce
moment en France tuig non est-ce que
Mick Jager laisserait sa fille épouser
un
journaliste
est-ce que les Rolling St les femmes et
les enfants se réunissent le dimanche
pour
piquerer compil prendre sa retraite un
jour non je pas non je pas arrê
travailler trava pour nonir
France